l'enfant de la batterie
doit
1944 le général de gaulle était l'idole
des français l'homme qui les avaient
guidé aux jours sombres de l'occupation
il semblait causeur triomphale de la
libération la france lui en serai
éternellement reconnaissante
deux ans plus tard de gaulle s'était
retiré à colombey les deux églises
écoeuré par la médiocrité politicienne
il n'avait pas libéré la france pour
s'occuper du montant de la ration de
pain
confiant il attendait que ses
compatriotes le rappel au pouvoir mais
les années passèrent douze années et
l'appel ne vint pas
en ce printemps 2009 158 avec une france
épuisé par la guerre d'algérie avec une
armée au bord de la révolte avec une
classe politique impuissante son heure
était peut être venu
[Musique]
on la bruja tableau dévastée balade à
moto afin de les adapter à l'écart
des côtes
j'adore
[Musique]
la baule où j'adore
aux champs elysées les vétérans de la
guerre d'algérie manifestent contre les
mauvais traitements réservés par les
rebelles aux prisonniers français
l'explosion d'une bombe au milieu de la
foule transforme la manifestation en
émeutes
et vétérans exaspérés ça lance à
l'assaut de la police avec ces
perpétuels changements le gouvernement
la quatrième république n'avait plus
guère de défenseurs
les déceptions causées par la situation
en afrique du nord les preuves que cette
guerre épuisante représente pour la
france et ses soldats et pour leurs
familles débouche sur ces affrontements
on compte cinq blessées et une quinzaine
d'arrestations
symptômes du malaise qui ronge la vie
politique de la france et dont on se
demande si elle guérir un jour pour les
algériens la réponse à cette question
était simple quand les français ont
quitté notre pays mais c'était de ne pas
tenir compte des réalités
entre temps les populations étaient
toujours coincés entre les combattants
du fln le front de libération nationale
et l'armée française laquelle jouer un
rôle politique de plus en plus grands
les villages entiers cherché refuge au
maroc et en tunisie les généraux
s'irritait du sanctuaire coffret ces
deux pays au fln et se plaignait d'attac
depuis des bases situées au delà des
frontières
il réclamait un droit de poursuite
au début de février 1958 suite à de
soi-disant tirs contre un avion
d'observation cela déboucha sur le
bombardement de la ville tunisienne de
sackey
si les généraux français avaient cru
résoudre leurs problèmes par ce
bombardement ce fut une grave erreur la
destruction de cette ville tunisienne
attira plus que jamais l'attention
internationale sur la guerre d'algérie
il eu 80 morts dont de nombreux enfants
et plus de 100 blessés les français
avaient prétendu que s'inquiète était
une base du fln la presse internationale
immédiatement sur les lieux n'en trouva
aucune trace
mais tunisie porte à la question devant
les nations unies
les ennemis de la france triompher
la grande bretagne et les etats unis
très embarrassés s'offrir comme honnêtes
courtiers parient accepta à la fureur
des généraux
la destruction d'installations de la
croix rouge neda pas la thèse française
de la provocation
le ministre de la défense avait parlé de
destruction d'un nid de rebelles et
d'assassins et d' acte de légitime
défense
mais les images de cette école détruite
répandue dans le monde lui était un
cruel démenti car des bombes étaient
tombés pendant les cours et le nombre
les enfants tués étaient élevés
le réalisateur français rené vautier
tournait alors un documentaire sur le
fln il se précipita à sa quête son
témoignage bouleversant l'opinion
quand confrontés à des images de
cadavres d'enfants les généraux
persistèrent a parlé de provocation
même les amis de la france furent
choqués les politiciens à paris près à
leurs distances avec les militaires ce
qui rendit ceci encore plus furieux
il dans leur souci d'aider au maximum la
cause du fln les tunisiens organisèrent
de véritables visites guidées pour les
diplomates
il était évident qu'il serait unanime à
condamner l'action de la france
entre temps les bombes non explosées
éparpillés dans la ville était
complètement exposées
et diplomates furent aussi conduit au
chevet des blessés la sphère de sa quête
paraissait avoir anéanti tout espoir de
paix et pourtant les colons restait
convaincu que la chose était encore
possible
le désordre règne alger craignant d'être
abandonnés par paris les colons en appel
à la grève générale
et c'est par milliers que les
pieds-noirs participent à une
manifestation monstre dirigée par le
général salan chef de l'armée en algérie
alger n'était que complot ont comploté
pour le retour de de gaulle ont comploté
pour un putsch des généraux
l'attitude de salles en reste équivalent
restera-t-il loyales au gouvernement
désigné par l'assemblée nationale ou
bizarre at-il sur de gaulle
détient-il vraiment le pouvoir en
algérie ou n'est-il qu'un prête-nom sa
langue était le soldat le plus décoré de
france le plus mystérieux aussi
on côté de salon
celui que l'on considère comme le
véritable chef du mouvement le général
massu le commandant des parachutistes
l'élite de l'armée en algérie membre du
comité de salut public massue tu es le
symbole et le porte parole de la révolte
des généraux
sa présence en flammes l'entousiasme des
colons obstinément opposée à tout
compromis avec les nationalistes
déçus par les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé à paris les manifestants se
ruent vers le gouvernement général ou
leur fureur se donne libre cours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le drame de la france un pays
théoriquement paix n'a plus de limites
quand le général massu dit je ne peux
pas garantir qu'il n'y aura pas de bain
de sang il dit la vérité trop de
rancoeur rend vaine une telle promesse
[Musique]
partout retentit le cri de gaulle au
pouvoir un cri dont l'écho parvient
jusqu'à paris la réponse ne se fait pas
attendre le président du conseil imola
un proclame l'état d'urgence
cependant en algérie tout le monde
n'était pas gaulliste pendant la guerre
la plupart des colons avaient opté pour
pétain et le gouvernement pro allemand
de vichy contre de gaulle et les
français libres de l'ombre de gaulle ne
l'avait pas oublié et tenez en piètre
estime les patriotes d'alger du danger
avant de dans sa marche vers le pouvoir
après ce serait une autre affaire
[Applaudissements]
les exécutions de prisonniers de guerre
par le fln avait déchaîner la fureur des
généraux le télégramme envoyé par salon
à paris avait déclenché la crise la
formation le 13 mai d'un comité de salut
public à alger ce prélude traditionnel à
un changement de régime pour les
français était un défi à l'autorité du
gouvernement de paris
s'il y avait eu un gouvernement de fait
il n'y en avait plus depuis tout un mois
opinions exprimées dans la rue et des
cordons de police entourant le palais
bourbon n'arrêtait pas toujours les
manifestants
la manifestation tourne à la bataille
rangée
furieux les vétérans hurle de gaulle au
pouvoir les députés à la scène
place de la concorde la vague de
violence se heurte aux crs
dans l'hémicycle après des semaines de
tergiversations les députés votent la
confiance à pierre pflimlin président du
mouvement républicain populaire
un vote qui est sans doute la
conséquence et putsch des généraux c'est
à une large majorité que les députés
approuvent la promesse du gouvernement
de défendre la constitution
après avoir rencontré le président coty
monsieur pflimlin et ses ministres vont
devoir ramener les généraux dans le
droit chemin
il n'y avait pas que les généraux tout
alger en ce mois de mai 58 était en
folie qui est noir et musulman
s'agglutiner autour du gouvernement
général le 16 mai trois jours à peine
après le putsch survint la chose la plus
extraordinaire de cette période
extraordinaire ce qu'on a appelé la
fraternisation des musulmans depuis la
fin de la bataille d'alger un an
auparavant les relations entre les deux
communautés étaient restés tendus
jusqu'à lors le putsch et l affaire des
européens et voilà que surgissaient des
cortèges de musulmans brandissant des
calicots favorables à l'armée et à de
gaulle les familles étaient majoritaires
certaines sans leur voile ces cortèges
furent accueillies avec enthousiasme
même si leur présence n'était pas aussi
spontané que les pieds noirs auraient
voulu le faire croire ce fut un des
moments les plus émouvants de toute
cette guerre
sans doute certains furent t-il
persuader de manifester par l'armée
encore effrayante dans la casbah il n'en
reste pas moins vrai que de plus en plus
de musulmans étaient fatigués de la
guerre et espérer que de gaulle y
mettrait fin
[Applaudissements]
tandis que se décide le sort de la
france l'algérie vit en état séparé avec
son gouvernement le comité de salut
public
il n'est pas pour ce comité ou pour de
gaulle a intérêt à me taire car tout le
monde en algérie et gourry
le général massu reste la clé de voûte
du comité le général salan restant à la
tête de l'armée
tous deux déclarent vouloir à tout prix
éviter la rupture avec paris et ne voir
pour cela que de gaulle en attendant ces
deux généraux mène le jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez dès qu on agit on est
toujours discutée est un surtout à
partir des gens qui ne quittent pas leur
fauteuil le groupe rebelle en question
ce fut le comité de salut public du 13
mai
dont j'ai accepté
d'assurer la constitution et la
présidence dans la nuit du 13 mai et
sous la pression des événements et à la
demande d'un certain nombre de jeunes
gens et qui s'était emparée du
gouvernement général donc avait commis
un premier acte séditieux auquel les le
défenseur du palais lui même dit de ne
pas pu se poser
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ces gars on
voulait et ce comité sur les publics
étaient chargés d'abord il comprenait
pas seulement
des des français d'algérie il comprenait
aussi des arabes il prenait des kabyles
c'était donc une émanation de l'ensemble
de la population algérienne et
il me semblait profondément que ses ses
souhaits et s à étaient normaux car que
voulait-il il réclame est à paris un
gouvernement de salut public qui enfin
soit capable de régler sérieusement le
problème algérien c'était donc tout à
fait
régulier pour un pour le général chargée
du maintien de l'ordre à alger
d'employer le procédé peut être
extraordinaire mais efficace que j'ai
employé à savoir la constitution
d'acceptation de de la présidence de ce
comité
l'arrivée du héros des pieds-noirs
l'ancien gouverneur général jacques
soustelle fait encore monter la bière
evans et de france malgré les efforts du
gouvernement et de sa police il est venu
se joindre au comité de salut public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cris de ses partisans oblige bientôt
monsieur soustelle apparaître au balcon
il y proclament que l'algérie est plus
française que jamais nous devons
persévérer jusqu'à la victoire de gaulle
et de coeur avec nous en afrique comme
en europe la france est à la croisée des
chemins lequel va t'elle emprunter
[Musique]
colombey les deux églises un petit
village endormi
la crise la place est soudain au coeur
de l'actualité
les journalistes s'y bousculent dans
l'espoir d'un mot général de gaulle
mais celui ci reste invisible
soudain alors qu'il a choisi l'homme du
moment convoque une conférence de presse
à l'hôtel du quai d'orsay à l'intérieur
plus de 600 journalistes et cameramen
succès des crises
indéfiniment les mêmes représentants des
mêmes partis se répartir se mélanger
dans les mêmes postes ministériels sont
qu'ils en sortent semblait venu
à une crise nationale
extrêmement grave
mais aussi ceux peut-être
le début d'une espèce de résurrection
est la question qui brûlait les lèvres
de tous les hommes de gauche ne pu être
évitée resterait-il un défenseur de la
démocratie ou serait-il un nouveau
dictateur
[Musique]
alger d événement précédait de gaulle
l'arrivée de ce stand n'avait pas été
très bien accueilli par les généraux qui
tenait à mener le jeu sans qu'un
politicien venu de paris ne s'en mêle et
la conférence de presse du général de
gaulle n'avait pas rendu salants et ses
compagnons plus heureux quant aux pieds
noirs la brève référence à alger les
inquiéter
[Applaudissements]
salon conscient de ses atouts et les
utilisent en faisait courir des bruits
d'intervention militaire en france
métropolitaine
le plan résurrection
car il faut l'appeler par son nom
a été dès le lendemain du 13 mai étudier
sitôt que nous avons eu le sentiment que
les choses pouvaient se dérouler comme
nous le pensions et selon les hypothèses
qui avaient été mises en place
je suis heureux qu'on n'ait pas eu à
faire et a surtout appliquer ce plan de
gaulle était d'accord non pas avant 13
mai et disons que pendant la période du
13 mai on lui avait dit on lui avait
fait savoir
qu'il se pourrait que si les choses tard
des tombes tenu des probabilités
délicate qui pouvait se faire jour avec
le parti communiste
eh bien on envisager
d'envoyer les parachutistes sur paris
disons que c'était un élément de
protection contre une contre opérations
menées par les communistes
oui ces plantes étaient prévus par mois
en liaison d'ailleurs avec avec paris
avec un certain nombre de gens qui ceux
qui avaient les mêmes désirs que nous à
savoir le retour au pouvoir du général
de gaulle
le général salan évidemment m'avait pas
tout à fait du même avis j'ai chargé mon
état majeur c'était à l'époque le gone
ducasse qui était mon chef d'état-major
de préparer dans le détail ces plans
comme comme ceux d'une opération
le vent levé essentielle étant le
transport il était assurée par mes
relations médias jean avec l'aviation
militaire dont une partie était tout à
fait d'accord et par une une compagnie
d'aviation civile
dont le
don le suit le soutien mettait tout à
fait acquis également
par conséquent les plantes est tout à
fait réalisable
est ce un hasard
toujours est-il qu'il accélére à son
retour au pouvoir
[Musique]
alors que la crise tendait à se calmer
la tension se porta de l'algérie à un
autre territoire français
sous le signe de la croix de lorraine la
corse à son tour suit l'exemple de
l'algérie et forme son comité de salut
public
l'envoyé spécial d'alger le général
n'est depuis roma zoo reçoit un accueil
tumultueux
ici aussi on réclame un changement pour
la france ici aussi on crie de god
[Musique]
constantine une des principales villes
d'algérie
la foule dans les rues témoigne lui même
enthousiasme pour le nouveau régime ici
aussi on en appelle à l'homme c'est une
fois déjà a conduit la france charles de
gaulle
l'algérie pose ses conditions à la
france
si de gaulle ne revient pas au pouvoir
le pire est à craindre
[Applaudissements]
tandis que les algérois savourer un
grand moment de leur histoire les
parisiens s'apprêtait d'heure en heure à
voir débarquer les parachutistes c'est
en france que ce jour est la suite de la
crise
l'elysée était moins du départ de
monsieur pflimlin et avec lui peut-être
du dernier gouvernement de la quatrième
république
le président du conseil s'étaient déjà
vus abandonné par certains ministres la
voie paraît libre pour de bon
le lendemain ou de théâtre à l'elysée
habile et courageux le président coty
fait savoir à l'assemblée nationale
qu'il a demandé au général de gaulle de
former le nouveau gouvernement
seule alternative selon le président à
une guerre civile
si l'assemblée c'est dans toute
manifestation de l'extrême gauche devait
rejeter le goal le président coty
démissionnerait
[Musique]
la situation évolue d'heure en heure
l'ancien président pierre mendès-france
reste opposé jusqu'au bout au général de
gaulle
l'argument des adversaires du général et
que celui ci est un fasciste qu'il
prépare le retour au pouvoir des
fascistes les gaullistes réplique que
tout dans le passé de de gaulle prouve
le contraire
les socialistes détiennent la clé de la
situation
leur leader monsieur guy mollet quitte
l'elysée pour conférer avec le général
de gaulle à colombey les deux églises
cependant paris reste calme
le parlement ou le général
les erreurs des politiciens ou les
dangers des généraux paris s'interroge
discute à temps mais ne s'affole pas
[Musique]
autour du parlement les crs montent la
garde mais les rues sont calmes ils ne
devront pas intervenir
après avoir accepté sa mission de
formateur le général de gaulle prend
congé du président coty le sort de la
quatrième république semble s'élever
à alger une foule immense célèbre la
victoire de de gaulle une victoire dont
elle se sent responsable
le général ne perd pas de temps si tous
confirmés par l'assemblée le
gouvernement se mette au travail
parmi ses membres on reconnaît l'ancien
président du conseil monsieur pflimlin
monsieur antoine pinay représentant les
conservateurs
monsieur guy mollet chef du parti
socialiste
tandis que paris célèbre la naissance de
la vème république
les députés écoute le nouveau premier
ministre leur réclamer les mesures
nécessaires à l'établissement du nouveau
régime
les pleins pouvoirs pour six mois et le
droit de réformer la constitution ce qui
lui accorde faute d'alternative
paris se rallie au général
[Applaudissements]
cette nuit là la capitale paraît comme
soulagé d'un grand poids
l'instabilité du régime aura coûté à la
france son empire le respect de
l'étranger et son rang de grande
puissance
avec de gaulle ces épreuves sont
peut-être arriver à leurs terres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la guerre civile était évité le
changement avait respecté la
constitution les français croyaient en
un nouveau départ
et les mouvements de foule énorme qui
demandaient le départ du gouvernement
français l'armée aurait pu maintenir
leur en tirant sur la foule l'armée peut
pas le faire nous sommes passés avec la
foule et avec elle nous avons demandé le
retour au pouvoir du général de gaulle
l'abbé c'est une grande force personne
pouvait s'opposer à nous quand on a pris
cette décision mais les gens rigolent
est revenu il a été plébiscité par toute
la foire dont nous avions raison et ceci
dit de voir le pouvoir les militaires
sont rentrés dans le rang machete
colonna j'ai un peu le commandant le
régiment j'ai ramassé commandes les
vélos il a repris
un des premiers actes posés par de
gaulle suite en juin 1958 de visiter
alger l'accueil fut extatique
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup parmi les pieds noirs qui
avaient participé au putsch du 13-mai
croyez avoir mis de gaulle dans leur
poche puisqu'il leur devais le pouvoir
dangereuse illusion comme l'a dit un de
ses adversaires chacun alger pendant ces
journées enfiévrée de juin 58 étaient
convaincus de détenir un fragment de la
vraie croix de lorraine
le 4 juin à 7h du soir exactement de
gaulle s'adresse à la foule depuis ce
même balcon d'où salants massue et les
autres avaient proclamé les putschs du
13 mai en le présentant salon déclare
avec passion notre grand cri de joie et
d'espoir a été entendu la foule rugy
longuement et les premiers mots que de
gaulle puis enfin prononcé fut répétée
pesé et analysé tant que durera la
guerre d'algérie
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai compris
rires
assurés et le mcee
à ceux qui pouvaient tout de la variole
[Applaudissements]
la mer
plus ce qui suit je n'ai senti
combien ces bleus
ont bien assez grand
combien ces généreux la boîte
[Applaudissements]
de gaulle poursuivi en déclarant qu'il
n'y avait dorénavant qu'une sorte de
citoyens en algérie avec les mêmes
droits que les français en france ce qui
pouvait déboucher sur l'indépendance
s'est elle était le vote de la majorité
des algériens mais bien peu
interprétèrent ses paroles dans ce sens
il n'avait pas prononcé algérie
française ce qui avait frappé certains
pieds noirs mais dans son dernier
discours au moment de retourner en
france il lâcha pour la première et
seule fois les deux mots fameux algérie
française les pieds noirs étaient
rassurés la tournée fut un succès
incontestable mais elle montre a
clairement qui était le patron le grand
avantage de de gaulle était qu'il
n'était en rien qu'on promet par les
décisions prises avant lui en algérie
son autorité était immense et incontesté
si quelqu'un parlait pour la france
c'était bien lui qu'il fit encore quatre
voyages en algérie cet été et cet
automne 58 mais jamais il ne retrouva le
triomphe de sa première visite et aucun
discours ni l'impact du je vous ai
compris
[Musique]
ah oui y avait-il quelque chose de
machiavélique dans l'attitude du général
de gaulle
je pense d'abord que tout diplomate doit
savoir qu'on est obligé dans les
affaires publiques et surtout dans des
affaires aussi difficile que la sphère
algériennes de ne pas toujours tout dire
dès le début et c'est vrai que de gaulle
n'a probablement pas tout dit dès le
début notamment aux européens est ce
qu'il leur a dit me paraissait tout de
même assez clair il leur a dit comme je
le rappelais tout à l'heure que rien ne
saurait imposer aux musulmans d'algérie
il leur a dit que puisque eux européens
se déclarait favorable à l'intégration
eh bien on allait en tout cas rendre les
algériens ego européen et on allait
faire quelque chose de politiquement
très important qui est de supprimer ce
qu'on appelait les deux collèges
autrefois les européen votait d'un côté
les musulmans votaient de l'aude et il
avait droit à la même représentation
c'est à dire que la voie d'un européen
valait 9 voix de musulmans de gaulle
tout de suite dès le début de juin 1954
quand il est arrivé à alger a dit le
fameux je vous ai compris je vois ce que
vous voulez faire vous voulez l'égalité
eh bien la voilà et la première égalité
je supprime les deux collèges et il a
dit ensuite l'avenir de l'algérie
dépendra des algériens dès lors qu'il
disait cela qu'est ce que cela
signifiait c'est que c'était la majorité
c'est à dire les musulmans d'algérie qui
en fin de compte trancherait et
déciderait du sort de l'algérie je crois
que ça n'est pas du tout machiavélique
d'avertissement aux européens
beaucoup ont prétendu que de gaulle est
une occasion en or de forcer une
solution en algérie pendant ces journées
est euphorique du début juin mais c'est
supposer qu'il possédait cette solution
qu'il y avait déjà pensé la vérité est
qu avant juin 1958 de gaulle n'avait
accordé que peu d'intérêt à l'algérie
ces véritables intérêts étaient
d'ailleurs à douar de la france au plus
tôt leurs établissements ces gloires
sali par la défaite de 1940 si une
algérie française pouvez y contribuer
tant mieux mais si une algérie française
mais des obstacles son choix est clair
en attendant les pieds noirs se
contentait de leurs illusions
pour nous c'était l'espoir on avait
l'impression que militairement nous
avions déjà gagné si vous voulez mais
politiquement il fallait gagner la
seconde bataille et on avait
l'impression qu'avec le général de
gaulle et on allait gagner la bataille
politique et nous avons été vite déçu
par la suite et nous pensions nous que
le 13 mai 58 qui est un mouvement très
généreux très fraternel allait permettre
de le faire pour instituer une dynamique
révolutionnaire d'égalité une espèce de
nuit d'une espèce de nuit du 4 août et
malheureusement la suite ne l'a pas
permis parce que le général de gaulle
n'a pas pris acte de cette volonté de
fraternisation et d'égalitarisme de la
part des français d'algérie qui avait
participé aux journées de 58 et
finalement tout est retombé très vite
le 14 juillet fait pour de gaulle
l'occasion de montrer à la france comme
il l'avait fait en algérie qui détenait
le pouvoir pour lui la priorité était
dorénavant la nouvelle constitution elle
serait soumise à référendum en septembre
et pour la première fois les algériens
des deux sexes musulmans comme européens
y aurait un droit de vote égal ensuite
en novembre il y aurait des élections
pour confirmer sa majorité suivi en
décembre par le choix d'un nouveau
président mais les français devaient
être convaincu les intérêts de de gaulle
dépassé les frontières mais il lui
fallait d'abord s'assurer d'une bonne
base nationale
[Musique]
place de la république est au coeur du
paris des travailleurs le général de
gaulle défend la nouvelle constitution
devant 10000 invités sélectionnés
l'accueil y est triomphe âge parmi les
auditeurs et ne marquant qu'un
enthousiasme mitigé le chef du dernier
gouvernement de la quatrième république
monsieur pierre vimont
non loin de là une manifestation
violente était organisée par le parti
communiste
la foule était estimée à cent mille
personnes
les communistes furent les opposants les
plus acharnés de de gaulle durant la
campagne du référendum si pas les seuls
leurs penseurs jean paul sartre par là
de sa constitution du mépris et dit
qu'il voterait plutôt pour dieu car il
était plus modeste mais la cause était
entendue il était clair que de gaulle
l'emporterait
les commentaires d actualité ne cherchez
même plus apparaître objectif
bordeaux ne cache pas qu'elle apportera
un soutien massif à de gaulle lors du
référendum à l'exception des communistes
tenus à l'écart par la police la foule
réserve au général en accueil
inoubliable à rennes l'enthousiasmé des
bretons n'est pas moins grand
tout au long de sa campagne en faveur de
la nouvelle constitution
et malgré des oppositions les foules
fürth en faveur du général
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est à lille sa ville natale que
le triomphe de charles de gaulle atteint
son apogée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paris comme toute la france ne pensez
plus qu'au référendum et la
participation s'élève à à 85% il fallait
dire oui ou non à la nouvelle
constitution
même les malades pure beauté
onu traitons le sentiment que de gaulle
obtiendrait la majorité nécessaire des
deux tiers on ne voulait plus des
erreurs de la quatrième république
de fait la nouvelle constitution
recueilli 80 % de 8
le général voté à colombey les deux
églises il n'eut qu'un bulletin non de
gaulle déclara que ce n'était pas le
sien
la défaite des communistes du général en
algérie où réside le plus grave problème
auquel il devra faire face de gaulle
recueilli
97% des suffrages en sa faveur hommes et
femmes musulmans votée séparément ici
comme en france l'autorité du général
sera indiscutable et certains ne
cachaient pas leur soutien
[Musique]
en novembre de gaulle emporta largement
la majorité aux élections la gauche fut
décimée en particulier les communistes
de même en décembre l'élection d'un
nouveau président étaient gagnés
d'avancé et au début janvier 59 de
gaulle se préparer à succéder au
président coty pour tenter de gagner la
majorité musulmane en algérie de
nombreux prisonniers effet l'aisne avait
été amnistié le jour de son inauguration
de gaulle comme lui a toutes les peines
de mort prononcées au cours de la
bataille d'alger en peine de prison à
vie et à celle saadi en bénéficia
notamment trois mois auparavant de
gaulle avait offert la paix des braves
dont personne n'avait voulu ni le fn ni
les pieds noirs qui commençait à se
poser des questions à son sujet cette
opposition abrupte à une première
tentative de paix consternant de gaulle
[Musique]
sept mois après son accession au pouvoir
si la vème république était fermement
établie d'une solution en algérie
paraissait plus éloignées que jamais
beaucoup avaient le sentiment qu'il
avait manqué le coche en ne profitons
pas en juin 58 de l'énorme popularité
dont il jouissait temps parmi des colons
que parmi les musulmans cette lune de
miel ne se reproduirait plus la
cérémonie de passation des pouvoirs en
ce jour de janvier 1959 fut émouvante
au début de la cérémonie le général
catroux passeront cause du futur
président de la république son ancien
compagnon d'armes le collier d'or de la
légion d'honneur
président coty décor qu avec de gaulle
la france triomphera d'elle-même
elle était au bord de l'abyme
qu'à son tour
elle a fait appel au général de gaulle à
la fin de son allocution le nouveau
président laisse percer son émotion les
membres à présent
ou à l'horizon paraît la lumière de nos
grandes espérances
vive la communauté vive la république
sont dans ces temps de gaulle présidera
aux destinées de la vème république
tous les avis de la france forme des
voeux pour ce grand pays et son nouveau
président
[Musique]
pour consolider son pouvoir de gaulle
avait discrètement purger l'armée
d'algérie des officiers qui avaient été
à l'origine des événements de mai 58 le
dernier à s'en aller quelques semaines
avant son inauguration avait été le
général salan lui même il avait été
nommé gouverneur militaire de paris un
poste purement honorifique une
humiliation qu'il ne pardonnerait jamais
si de gaulle se permettait de telles
mesures c'est que la situation militaire
tournait en faveur des français
révélaient était en pleine déconfiture
depuis qu'en septembre 1957 bien avant
de gaulle on avait établi la ligne
morice
andré maurice était alors ministre de la
défense et son nom allez passer à la
postérité comme vingt ans plus tôt celui
infortunés de son prédécesseur andré
maginot la ligne consistait en un réseau
savant de barbelés de bobby traps le
champ de mines qui s'étendaient le long
de la frontière tunisienne est destinée
à couper le ravitaillement et les
renforts des maquis de l'intérieur à
bout de munitions manquant d'hommes ce
site serait amené à se rendre
franchir la ligne de 20 dans l'objectif
numéro un du fln qui se heurtait à une
force de 80000 sommes bien entraînés
toute tentative de franchissement de
cette ligne longue de 300 km et
s'étendant de la mer au sahara était
immédiatement détecté le fln l'a pris à
ses dépens en sept mois il y perdit 6000
hommes
la nuit les projecteurs éclairer le
secteur les champs de mines étaient
particulièrement meurtriers couper des
vents forts tunisien le moral des
combattants de l'intérieur se détériorer
après un sursaut leurs attaques ces
serres presque entièrement ce qui permit
aux français d' encore renforcé les
effectifs à la frontière ses effectifs
qui jouissait du maximum de confort au
contraire des milliers de fln regroupés
en tunisie
[Musique]
l'armement des français étaient
abondants toute brèche dans la ligne
détecter par radar était automatiquement
arrosé par l'artillerie la barrière de
barbelés haute de deux mètres cinquante
était la nuit parcouru par un courant de
cinq mille volts et la contourner par le
sud est et 20 la région n'offrant aucune
protection contre l'aviation française
[Musique]
la plupart des combats se déroulaient
dorénavant dans le secteur de la ligne
morice et l'arrivée au pouvoir de de
gaulle avait coïncidé avec les plus
lourdes pertes subies par le fln dans
ses tentatives de franchissement une
ligne semblable mais moins
perfectionnées avait d'ailleurs coupé
tous vents forts venant du maroc
le fait que
lorsque des unités adverses est élevée
on savait qu'elle était leur point de
passage leur lieu de ravitaillement que
petit à petit on avait coupé les les
axes de progression de ses unités leurs
hôpitaux leurs centres de
ravitaillements bref que là
les unités étaient prises à la gorge en
réalité il y a eu un renversement
jusqu'en 58 le fln était maître de
l'algérie
totalement la nuit par exemple elle ne
s'en est pas aperçu et nous à partir de
59 nous étions les maîtres de la gérer
la nuit le jour certainement et la nuit
à peu près partout quand même
les troupes qui gardait la ligne morice
ignorait à quel point la situation de
leurs adversaires étaient graves mais 58
avait pris le fln par surprise et dans
un premier temps il s'était montré
incapable de réagir mais il n'empêche
les soldats français n'en restait pas
moins nerveux
[Musique]
quelqu'un tirait la
caisse qui a tiré
c'est que ce merdier là vous avez vu
quelque chose
et si vous avez vu
huy sont la gaillarde tarbes
merde à vous les avez vu derrière
l'arbre
gpo plus
jamais le fln ne relâche pas sa pression
il ne fallait pas que les français
soupçonnent les dissensions qui régnait
en son sein en particulier les
récriminations des maquis de l'intérieur
contre le manque de soutien des forces
de l'extérieur
récriminations qui nierait qu'en
s'amplifiant jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
le fln ne pourrait jamais égalé la
puissance militaire de la france sa
force résidait dans sa diplomatie
en 1959 le caméraman indépendant e rgp
rire accompagna le fln dans une
opération parti de tunisie
des
jeux
ces dissensions et est pain béni pour
les officiers de renseignement comme le
capitaine léger effectivement le fhaine
bourré de haine de jalousie
et d'ailleurs il ne se privait pas de
régler leurs comptes entre eux mêmes à
l'échelon ce qu'il disait nationale
s'est tenue hier à l'échelon du gpr à du
gouvernement provisoire de la république
algérienne qui se trouvait à tunis à
l'époque où il y avait des gens qu'on
est assassiné sur ordre du gpr à des
gens qui étaient même au sein du gpa
mais qui peut-être prenez une importance
trop grande au gré de certains de leurs
collègues et ces gens là ont été
assassinés bon ce qui se passait donc au
sommet se passer également à la base
ce qui fait que naturellement
il nous était relativement facile
d'exploiter tout
cnc rancune simplement par le jeu de la
manipulation et le jeu de l'intoxication
les méthodes des collègues du capitaine
léger pour intoxiquer et manipuler des
moujahidines était infini et payantes
lui plus de nationalistes algériens tués
par d'autres nationalistes algériens que
par les français l'élimination des
groupes rivaux avaient toujours été la
priorité numéro un pour le fln malgré
les efforts de la direction extérieures
du mouvement ces luttes souvent tribal
mener à des massacres dont les français
est allé complaisamment l'épreuve devant
la presse internationale
réplique à la sphère de sackey
ces soupçons ces oppositions entre
groupes raciaux sur le point faible du
mouvement même quand ils parvenaient à
en dissimuler les traces une foire et
filtrer le fln en algérie devient une
proie facile pour le capitaine léger il
ne fallait pas grand chose pour qu un
maquis en liquide un autre la haine qui
les opposait étaient souvent plus grande
que la haine des français
les chefs du fln santec avec le retour
de de gaulle l'initiative était dans le
camp français pour renverser cette
situation
une conférence de presse convoquée au
caire en septembre aux 58 annonce à la
formation d'un gouvernement provisoire
dont le premier président fut ferhat
abbas un dur belkacem krim était vice
président ceci pour reprendre
l'initiative diplomatique
votre douce
note qu on s'entête
[Musique]
segment sauvetage public opinion
très doux et sexy de tous obtiennent
support du standing
32 face sommes l'american 13 ex aequo
zilla
argentine à
vignoux les indépendants
ce qui concerne les pays socialistes
nous avons eu le soutien moral et
politique
de 1954 à 1962 mais
dead financières et matérielles
et on a eu peu
eu de l'aide aux réfugiés
aides sociales comme soigner des blessés
en urss
il ya eu par contre de la chine une aide
importante à partir de 1960
mais contrairement à ce qui se disait
dans la presse française ce n'était pas
l'union soviétique et les pays
communistes qui nous ont aidé et il nous
a aidés politiquement et moralement mais
leur aide matérielle je le dis n'était
pas à la hauteur de ce que nous pouvions
espérer mais c'était quand même
important quand on songe que de l'autre
côté les pays occidentaux et des larmes
et colonialiste à nous écraser avait une
différence entre ceux qui nous aident et
peu et ceux qui étaient contre
[Musique]
si en 1959 et sur le front diplomatique
les français étaient perdants sur le
front militaire il l'emportait de loin
de gaulle qui voulait négocier depuis
une position de force avait ordonné la
plus grande offensive que le fln est
jamais subi mais sans en donner les
raisons politiques au général challe le
nouveau commandant en chef il n'avait
confié qu'à quelques intimes un autre
motif important à cette offensive
éloigner les militaires de la politique
donnez-leur beaucoup de travail
disent-ils ils penseront -
la tactique de challes était simple on
concentrait toutes ses forces dans un
secteur on le nettoyait de tout maquis
puis ont passé aux secteurs suivants
tout cela grâce principalement aux
harkis ces unités musulmane de l'armée
française
toujours n'était pas question pour les
pieds noirs de négocier tant qu'on se
battait ni pour le fln de cesser les
combats avant que la négociation ne
commence la quadrature du cercle la
seule différence était que l'homme qui
maintenant prenez les décisions ne
dépendait plus du lobby algérois il
était même de plus en plus sourd aux
récriminations des pieds noirs à qui il
ne pardonnait pas de lui avoir préféré
pétain pendant la guerre
la fin 2009 159 vies l'apogée des
combats en algérie les pertes du fln
était terrible beaucoup déserté
on faisait de plus en plus de
prisonniers le maquis de l'intérieur
était en plein désarroi mais les
généraux français commencé à comprendre
que la victoire des armes ne suffirait
pas
la victoire militaire en algérie a été
totale a été absolument totale c'est une
chose que l'on oublie toujours les
katiba ont été cassées les petits
groupes qui galopait été dessinés au fur
et à mesure en tout cas il n'avait plus
de prestige et de plus de moyens de
pressions directes sur les villages même
si ces villages demeurait de demeurer
partisans de l'indépendance n'était pas
ce n'était pas une révolte c'était une
révolution que nous vivions il s'agit
c'est pas pour nous il ne s'est pas agi
en 1954 de débarquer en france d'écraser
l'armée française
forte de centaines de milliers d'hommes
de chars d'avions de croiseurs non il
s'agit ici n'est pas de faire une guerre
classique
nous ne pouvions pas faire une guerre
classique contre l'armée française nous
l'avons alors je crois que si on parle
de victoire militaire elle était acquise
il est difficile de le situer dans les
années 59 60 mais si on parle de
victoire de tout court elle n'était pas
acquise car dans toutes ces guerres
révolutionnaires que monsieur
khrouchtchev appelle les guerres de
libération nationale
la victoire militaire n'a aucune
importance ce qui est important c'est
une solution politique et il n'y en
avait pas
[Musique]